[Music]
so uh russia recently increased their uh
global threat level by running a test of
their intercontinental ballistic news oh
[ __ ] guess what that nuke is called
what's the name of that missile the
hospital
the hospital big husband it's tiny but
but mighty bro oh
putin's penis
that's pretty good now what would like a
russian guy name it oh no peace
i'm going to send peace
it's actually called the satan 2.
that's a sick name actual satan gangster
as [ __ ] dude
so does that mean like the rest of the
world is like what the [ __ ] is going on
no that's the thing that's weird is that
um ev the rest of the world generally is
like he's just flexing that's a normal
test you have to do anyway they're like
they always say that yeah but that's i
think obviously they're gonna say
something that won't make everyone panic
you know that's very true but this
missile has a range of eleven thousand
two hundred miles and it has enough
power to erase france but can they reach
america yeah why why they gotta choose
why i gotta pick up france
if they were to do nukes if they hit new
york you didn't mean like new york is a
hot target you mean it's right there on
the coast it's like the closest thing
but i probably goes new york new jersey
like how what's the size of france in
that oh bro you're knocking out that
entire life but it's [ __ ] all of new
england so it's not technically a
nuclear missile but it's nuclear capable
so they could just put a nuclear warhead
inside of it and it's said to be the
world's longest range intercontinental
ballistic missile man we would not he
also brags that there's no current
defense system that can target it whoa
that's kind of scary elon please help us
dude yeah but then the u.s described the
testing as routine and dismissed any
global they always do that though yeah
who said that jan saki my girl jen
that's his girl dude that's my girl dude
what if the u.s is like man that's why
we've been having a space force full you
don't even know what we got yeah see
that was that's what my question was
like what's up with the space force
they've been real quiet so maybe they're
just like yeah they're moving in silence
they're moving i like it i kind of like
it
maybe they'll like uh intercept it from
out of space from the moon yeah whoa
that'd be tight yeah so if fully armed
it really actually says it can deliver a
payload big enough to destroy an area
the size of france france is pretty big
so they mean we're going to blow up
france next
i mean out of all the european countries
though france is 210 000 square miles
everywhere else is please keep beautiful
friends but paris is okay you could hit
paris so remember when putin said like
oh if anyone like [ __ ] with us you'll
you'll experience a level of like
destruction that the history has never
seen yeah yeah i remember you said that
bro satan too
that's a crazy name can't wait for the
third one i hope not that's why i'm like
let's get this video out before people
[ __ ] go how insensitive of you to
make a video of the [ __ ] after after
he [ __ ] blows up france oh geez
it's high stakes here well i mean damn
it's getting harder to do our job as
comedy that is wait eleven thousand
miles you said that's how far goes it
can travel can we measure how far is is
is russia from from new york city how
far eleven hundred miles or eleven
thousand wow that's [ __ ] funny oh
dude that can reach here it can go
double the distance and then come back
around that she could [ __ ] circle
around the globe bro that [ __ ] could go
to new york and back
wait what is the what is the what is the
miles go to new york flex
russia layover in new york
we're here to go back
they could do a [ __ ] round trip
hopefully it does that it just blows
itself up
they miscalculate it's like oops goes
back around russia have you guys seen
the russian like military scrambling
though like ukraine's been whipping
their ass yeah so i don't know i don't
really have confidence in their ability
that's a good point you know like they
have their track record so far shows
that like their military is pretty
incompetent that's a good point because
they like other countries are saying the
reason that he's so public about this
test is because their recent technology
when practiced in war was a failure so
far
like all the stuff they've been bragging
about to this point has not really
worked so this one might go like
and then it's like oh malfunction and it
just falls yeah there's this uh video
it's like these russian tanks going into
ukraine
they get ambushed and then these guys
instead of having some sort of like
military order you just seem like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] and the fool's climbing out
of the tanks oh
my god it was just [ __ ] a [ __ ] show
i'm like what though no uh you know what
i heard is that some of those guys
thought they were in like a training
exercise and they when they when they
were getting shot at they're like
what the [ __ ] were in war and then there
they they just all jumped out started
surrendering how would they jump out of
the tank they're just freaking out load
themselves into the turret
get me out of here
here like so in the american military
like the objective and your mission
is extremely important because if you're
lost from your squad or your platoon or
your leaders you still know what you're
supposed to do if you're stranded in a
jungle you know exactly what you're
supposed to do eat banana but not right
and then so like that's they're never
gonna send you and not tell you what's
happening you need to have a north star
so is it [ __ ] that they didn't know
where they were at oh no for them i
don't know what oh russians are crazy is
it possibly yeah you know i just need to
rally as many troops as possible you can
totally see them just shipping it out
they're running out of gas all that but
i i heard that like a lot of their uh
military too didn't have much practice
and training it's been so many years
since they took the warship series we've
been at war forever they were so corrupt
for the last 40 years of like not really
being in wars and [ __ ] that they're like
we're not going to be in a war so they
started selling off the equipment and
like
parts and then they weren't redoing the
[ __ ] they were building the government
so then like there was this real big
corruption
in the military where you know how like
the military they get funding by
government budgets right so then they
get the government budgets and then like
they have to spend it all so then
basically they're like embezzling the
government budget and then they'll
they're supposed to buy like let's say
new tires or some [ __ ] but instead of
buying new tires they just use the money
for other [ __ ] or they just fatten up
their own pockets
basically a lot of our spending goes to
rehearsals that's how you stay sharp we
do all those tests you know yeah like
like every single like marine that comes
out of boot camp has shot over a
thousand rounds wow and then fighter
jets are doing rehearsals they're like
practicing like dropping missiles making
sure they're hitting targets so a lot of
the most of the money is spent on
rehearsals and rehearsals and rehearsals
throughout your whole career yeah that
costs so much so if you're not
rehearsing then they don't they have
this surplus of a budget and they still
need to spend it it's but you can
clearly tell that they suck so does the
air force really also have to rehearse
like ejection from the plane all of that
every single they'll just let it crash
as a rehearsal yeah they'll have to it's
really i find it really funny that the
military calls it rehearsals i'm calling
it rehearsals oh yeah
training training yeah rehearsals i like
that better yeah
i got you had to go to rehearsal it's an
acting class
stage combat
yeah it's like a plane
and scene
[Laughter]
it's
[Laughter]
call for fire training environments
where like uh like someone like don or
another guy like a fart observer like
you would be there they would call in
the coordinates to have the planes come
in and because the missiles are [ __ ]
millions of dollars you'll see will
rehearse like all day
with just uh the planes coming in and
then the next day when it's ready
they'll drop the one or two missiles
so that they don't so they can get get
the almost like when you're shooting
like you dry fire right so you don't
waste your bullets so we'll do all those
reps and then the next day is when they
drop the actual missile wow and all that
cross monitors that's all yeah that's
the dresser
so then did you ever have to are there
you know when there's rehearsals for
like extraction or like trying to save
somebody and then there's a guy who just
plays like a person being safe oh yeah
yeah yeah who are those people they're
not extras
oh so you had to do that too get them
from sadly that's what we do let's say
we do an evacuation uh drill over
playing his role i just need you to shut
up
bang you're dead bang you're dead and
then they'll run the scenario so you two
get to chill
oh so you have to really actually be
dead weight huh yeah and they're just
bodies like this and you can't help even
though if you know the answers or like
he's supposed it's like escape room
[Laughter]
[ __ ] damn that's tight i didn't know
that did you just take turns baby he's
in the wall right there
it's literally like sports right like
you have to run those plays running
drills over and over and over so that
when you play the actual team you know
this guy passes the ball to that person
that passes the ball to that person
because it doesn't magically happen
right man the military's just larping
half the time they are they're larping
themselves to be honest to be ready but
the russians ain't oh
how much larping do they do that's why
when the [ __ ] hits the fan they're
[ __ ] scrambling all over the place yo
have you seen those like spent naz like
[ __ ]
training videos and like they have those
like russian military like
special forces videos it looks so dope
dude and then the reality is where the
[ __ ] did those guys go where are those
guys at they've been in the i mean
they've been in the war for a minute now
and i'm surprised they didn't even
because i heard in the beginning they're
like oh no what they're doing is russia
just sending in their [ __ ] troops to
tire out ukrainians and then they're
going to bring in the bad asses do you
think that's impossible and then but
look at how long it's been i know man
ps5s are still sold out bro yeah for
real
i thought they were gonna like shut them
down in like 48 hours or something
they're like ukraine that tiny ass
country and they were bragging about
that
hell nah but also they have so much uh
foreign support like ukraine has all of
our like funding i feel like they're
always saying they don't have enough to
like outlast
didn't we just give them like
like two 2.5 trillion dollars or some
[ __ ] they got a lot of bitcoin and [ __ ]
all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is that thing
skylink link internet yeah bro they're
hooked up we ain't even got skyler i
know yeah give us that
i'm trying to watch these tick tock
stuff
you guys will be tick tocks i gotta
watch
[Music]
[Music]
you